American Sniper is currently one of the most
popular movies in the country. It's about
the life of Chris Kyle, the sniper with the
most confirmed kills in American military
history. It focuses on his life, his failures,
his successes, and the trauma that he experienced
as a soldier. But viewers of the movie may
be surprised at the way that it talks about
the Iraq War in general. From the very beginning
of Kyle's military career, it's about a response
to terrorism. He joins the military after
we see the bombings of American embassies
in Kenya and Tanzania. And we see his and
his wife Taya's stunned reaction to 9/11.
But then bam. Shortly after that...  "I just got the call, boys. It's on!"
Kyle's at war in Iraq. There's no intervening time spent on George W. Bush, weapons of mass destruction
(WMD), or Saddam Hussein. The implication
that the viewer gets is that the invasion
of Iraq was a logical response to 9/11.
Of course, that's not actually what happened.
We know that after 9/11, the US invaded Afghanistan,
were Al Qaeda actually was. The decision to
invade Iraq came as a result of a preexisting political
project that members of the Bush administration
had and was sold on the pretense of weapons
of mass destruction in Iraq. "The main reason
we went into Iraq at the time was we thought
he had weapons of mass destruction. It turns
out he didn't, but he had the capacity to
make weapons of -- but I also talked about
the human suffering in Iraq. And I also talked
the need to advance a freedom agenda." In
the movie's narrative, there's no intervening
time between the American invasion and Kyle
fighting Al Qaeda in Iraq. "He's trained by
bin Laden. He's loyal to bin Laden. His name
is Zarqawi. Now this asshole is right now
the crown price of Al Qaeda in Iraq." That
leaves viewers with the impression that the
Iraq War was against Al Qaeda at the outset
and that America had invaded Iraq because
it had become a hotbed of Al Qaeda operations.
The reverse is true. Al Qaeda in Iraq grew
out of the American invasion. It was weak
and wasn't even Al Qaeda in Iraq when the
invasion happened. Its leader, Abu Musab
al-Zarqawi, correctly assessed that the US
invasion would allow him to build up his group.
Eastwood wanted to make a movie about one
guy. He didn't set out to make a movie about
the Iraq War. The problem is, though he himself
is anti-war, he ended up letting the film
get wrapped up in Kyle's perspective. "You
want these motherfuckers to come to San Diego
or New York? We're protecting more than just
this dirt." While it's easy to go sit at a
movie, especially one that tries hard not
to shove politics in your face, and appreciate
it as simply a movie about heroism, this movie
isn't just that. It's a movie that's going
to leave viewers with a false perception of what happened.